I'm drawing a figure 8 on the ground
I can't just do whatever nama straight
so all my young reconciliations yeah
yeah you had to come all the way around
okay but you did it with an extra step
and you wrong
[Music]
so you got pushed because you're pushing
on her oh you wait you got compromised
because you're pushing on her again
again let's go change partner Chris
you're with Margaret you're just put
getting away with it because you're
stronger than her here we are let's go
whoa oh wait what happened oh yeah your
vapor locking doesn't mind got jacked up
whoa do you see the elbow you see how
your hand slid over the top do you have
a young conflict at the elbow that you
just ignored with a lighter ETA trying
to get the pattern that little hip bump
because you're not grounding that foot
you're using your momentum to displace
her try to get the pattern
she's gotta come around you there you go
and then make her go wrong around you
but the hand is has to be on the hub so
your hand was off the elbow because the
Maya was too close so you tried to
create room do you see that
[Music]
whoops
a lot of y'all around you series right
here this technique could stop right
here do you see you can draw your weapon
so you can draw your knife right here oh
you don't want to push them into a knock
on like even if it did work even if it
did work you see that all the in
reconciliations are actually not just
theoretically sounder or philosophically
or spiritually sounder they are actively
sound okay so we'll bring this around in
here hold it will stop the technique
errors so he's in my hip now I'm taking
the elbow there right didn't draw your
knife hold boom right there in the
juggler
again it is very immediate oh okay let's
try it
no no no we're not doing easier now
which is part of eating he took a
concept for me killed while you missed
the entire leash they try not to do the
hip bump nope
let me see you're always you can't find
it you can push that oval right now my
doll your hips gonna do it don't go
don't rudder backwards
okay watch it yeah here I'll go around
and download the hip you see then this
arm passes around it's right there so
yeah I love the hip this arm goes around
our oh there's no need for steps that's
not what we're doing
okay so general key bone Wazza and cami
rules we condense the prescribed energy
in this case risk wrap cross lateral
push it second element I keep my Center
connected to my limbs okay and then the
third element I don't die that means if
it's a choice between Madeline on my
head and doing the first two i will not
land on my head do you understand okay
that's it that's all I do
so why we're doing this one is because
you guys keep pushing the elbow so I'm
trying to entice you in look this could
have been way over earlier by letting
the elbow around but you're still lured
to the pushing
so I put some gold in front of you and
now I'm going to show you you're not
dealing with silver you have in
front of you okay so when you do your
technique you push on that elbow okay
and if I just come in whoa
so which way to my average you want to
go it want to go backwards you see that
so that's where you should let the
energy here but you're trying to push it
and only the only problem is with that
just what yeah you yeah exactly
or maybe she's violating you can be
rules and it's going like this yeah you
see that difference you weren't told to
do that you're just totally coming in
and keep my Center didn't matter change
whoa do you understand so he's coming in
it's ever so slight this is how we start
with the classes you think you're doing
it but you're not it's ever so slightly
you are resisting so when I give you a
different technique that needs that
requires no resist there's no forward
progress hence you can't do it okay so
here's your tiny bit of resistance here
your body you try to push this you still
aren't having him up go around your hip
but you have it on the forward he goes
forward here and then you're doing that
you see that and what I'm doing is this
elbows going this way USBC that
different so that's where it is is as
you move this elbow market as a
nice face you move it forward his elbow
keeps going around me so that hence I
can do this technique you see you get it
so I want you to focus on the elbow it
cannot go forward in space that's going
to be a clash that you tend to get away
with because who gets turn turn
do you see and yet you get up or you're
stronger than you do can I just
technique is elbow keeps going around me
poom ok so we're working on that one
don't let the elbow go forward go
get it on your head
on your head
your your hit your arm is the Astra
sauce goes right to your hip better
so you see you want to push him don't
need that extra step
that's different pattern so if I change
the pattern it's because I'm not doing
the right Union young reconciliations
okay you have to let her pass you that's
not the pattern and the elbow does not
come back forward
right on your head make it tight let's
marshal it up right nope nope nope
switch roles
well you've changing the pattern you
have the wrong footwork
all the bass was weak so the elbows yen
but your bass is young so that's part of
the coordination right so you know
that's the problems like oh if I relax I
get mushy no no we don't yen's not mushy
okay go
lock it up so again
that's why I want you to marshal up your
yen is I'll go to sleep I'm gonna go to
I'm gonna go Mimi no well look at your
knee caving in and it's very important
that you kid doesn't start dancing for
us so your your elbow hand got jammed
well just because you're pressing on
your elbow
let it go by you so you don't have the
pattern so if you go off the pattern
then when we put this back in the
technique you're gonna be further away
from the technique
don't push it forward bring it around
you all but step inside you have the
patterns to do nope you milk the elbow
right you take your hand to get more
depth because you're getting pushed
you're pushing on it you're pushing on
it okay so you want down to you are very
interested in knocking them down did you
get it okay
let's do this kind of warrior pose right
here you see that now I'm going to just
do the obvious push his leg out you see
that you guys see that okay let's just
first look at the body naturally you can
relax right and you don't hold your
balance just left
yep okay so the body when you do this in
this center of gravity he's heavy on
this side and the body wants to go that
way that's right
when you came this way you lean this
that way do you understand
don't leave it just hang out lift it
just hang out do you see who wants to do
that
that is all I exaggerated when you share
and I did this he wants to do that this
come back this is gonna take strength
hmm see that difference okay so what
happens when his body comes in and I
stop his elbow the leg came up and then
when I do this with his body look he's
going into it you see he's going into
that balance do you understand
so I don't have to do this technique
like that I just have to set up that
Kazushi because I'm here so you can't
come the other way
and his inertia was going that way and
I'm just turning his head which would be
very much like making his foot go out do
you understand cuz if you watch this
head now when I push this this egg will
come towards me you see and that's all
I'm doing when I control his elbow here
so again you are taking him down I am
aiming at falling person do you see that
difference
[Music]
I'm not setting up a trip and doing that
I'm using the energy inertia the
momentum of the gravity that's all I'm
using I use it wool wool oh okay
let's try it again just set it up step
in step in and that's the problem
oh but I don't knock her the elbow goes
around me but my leg goes in
try not to knock her to try it you don't
need to twist her down
try to relax let her fall so he is you
got to get your IDI Mian your leg has to
get in there I said you have to look
there put in put in and wait and wait
more be patient
woo way is I'm not having to do
something I'm not forcing it okay it's
happening I'm allowing it to happen
better and now emotionally start
releasing mm you hit you hips bump turn
just wait just wait
taller people take longer to fall it's
like a big tree keep going
two more good wait
but keep devil there you go oh man
you're really pushing on that elbow it
would not work
yeah well comes this way but I have a
powder to do so your ad Mia's late okay
and your your anemias late because
you're pushing on the elbow and your
legs are being pinned by him do you
understand that so you can't step until
enough ahem goes into the fall which is
why you push on his hands as you're
trying to get him into the fall more
[Music]
don't use your hip
you got to get the powder and we are all
held to the pattern remember she's going
to fall anyways so let her fall that's
it
yes try to keep your foot lower there
you go good and he was not hitting my
legs so once he starts to fall I am
going to do something else I'm not going
to wait for him to get to the bottom
that is the next step
okay so it starts out exactly the same
he's going like that when you see he's
falling away he's here he's doing the
last technique but he's falling on the
next one
[Music]
so I do not wait and not go on like this
then I move door if I using the second
ticket in down you was already going
down
let's try
you gotta have your hand on the elbow
because if had you put your hand on the
elbow the yungyeong conflict would have
manifested but you took your hand off
the opener but so then you did weren't
really reconciling it the form is going
to guide you and cultivate you by
testing you okay go so you're a little
late and I'm wondering if it's because
your feet are being pin yeah you wait
for her to completely fall better there
you go
whoa so that looks like the whole
world's EQ everyone's pushing the elbow
everyone is taking someone down that
we're aiming falling people that is
totally pushing the elbow so you took
your hand off the elbow because you were
gonna push on it that is totally not
hard to go
keep the elbow coming backwards
[Music]
I dare you take something out of a front
you if you're using something we're
going to see when you do to technique
without it so if the person was falling
then I wouldn't need the lever fulcrum
of the arm I wasn't using a lever fault
do you understand so I want you to ask
yourself where are his hands as he's
doing the technique answer I'll never
because I want going like this you see
that
so I'm not shoving them down either
because if I did who would push its hand
out bottom of my thread I'm falling down
so when you guys have here you making
sure these arm doesn't go down my tactic
is different my attachment is I'm just
here following it if he pulls it in
I don't know the thing I just go on to
something off you're relying on it I'm
making him relying on me okay so we're
gonna get rid of that boom
better mindful of the elbow
[Music]
wrong pattern wrong pattern so you
stepped back because from the beginning
you already are antagonistic to him so
he's gonna push on you so you yielded
with a stepping back okay they do the
pattern you'll push in the elbow so she
has a lot of tension in her body and
he's triggering you she's gonna fall but
you didn't know you were gonna make the
fall yep there you go
but like all the wrists
[Music]
go
that's all clashing thought that is a
class so you you lift it up right you
all you're lifting up right against your
hands okay that's all but watch so
that's it y'all gon y'all now your turn
down really don't wanna know I'll show
y'all start adding my projections again
is it cuz you pushed on me so I can push
on you okay that's it that's not really
evening countering I'm just
demonstrating that you added a conflict
there it is again you guys see that way
but we keep thinking and it's not you
can't see it if you just were honest
enough all you gotta do is the geometry
so if I'm pushing down I don't know what
stuff that is just draw the line of my
vector and then if she lifts up against
it that's y'all on y'all that's we'll do
it again so lift up on it there you go
like that just stay right there and that
is the same geometry that allows me to
project throughs or the same geometry
that allows me to be stronger than her
and her down like that so your feet are
pinned right now boom right or gives me
enough time might need to come through
and go onto something
you bump in okay but we all but you can
see it and you definitely can feel it
hey so what we say about going backwards
is it about going backwards now it's not
about which ways that will go you gotta
lose that thrown in that rudder instead
[Music]
just wait for her
wrong powder and you can see your hand
came off the elbow because it was in a
young young conflict bong pattern okay
pick up the pace who can will amplify
the force contentions and then you
should be able to see the conflicts more
stick to your three rules who can
[Music]
do you see the adjustment step you took
okay cause you got displaced because you
were pushing on his elbow that that
looked like the same end
yeah so you got to get underneath my the
yen opening lady me ah she is under not
sideways under whoops pattern pattern
well there's a lot of arm strength right
see that means the elbow is going for
I'm trying to make it go forward but
that was her trick so the trick is
you're like I'm gonna go back I'm gonna
keep going backwards look you just have
moved the contention more eastward
that's all you've done it hasn't
reconciler because it hasn't been
deconstructed do you get it
okay go see the elbow will not go
backwards do that side again nope from
that side and the elbow must keep going
westward Wow on the other side of your
body
Wow that's all muscle
[Music]
okay reconciliation
you
so shrink your technique oh don't do
anything you can do you wait it so you
let your feet planted she pinned you
[Music]
they connected you got disconnected
right he's pinning your feet stay
connected you you move the arm up as
they're falling not after they hit the
ground after they hit the ground is
going to give them back the initiative
if you move to the new angle of zona
sanctuary right by the time he gets to
the ground then you have the upper hand
go
[Music]
experiment with you Cammie stick to the
rule
[Music]
you do this if you were not grounded on
this but if your center of gravity was
moving here you see that his Energy's
gonna push you off which is why you push
on the elbow which is also why you can't
stay up with the nasties falling because
you've got to wait for the weight to get
off so
[Music]
hey let's try
you
if you get experiment with you Kimmy
follow the rules you feel the world
[Music]
now you two need to change as you you're
pushing and you don't know it because
you're too light for each other but it's
you can feel your muscles okay
you just got away with it you're
prioritizing the technique over the
skill this is wrong go with the guys
there was do you see the the knee is
more from in place I'm not even walking
there so the knee is before I come
closer right there it is and stop
twisting her you remember you're holding
the elbow da too late then we flex our
knee when we were going to do the nice
try
Bush you got you got to be honest with
her running because she won't with
herself
pattern change wow that's a lot of
muscle just shoving the elbow which way
the elbow oh look at the arms win did
you see that wrist and elbow the arm is
not a fulcrum the only way I can make it
a fulcrum is if I push on the elbow
you'll push it on that elbow you need to
be looser
this risk like to being totally loose
lower center though because I got to be
under her that's better
and stop twisting the arm keep going
Leah your is never going to happen
towards the arm right did you feel it so
don't do it
hi